[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
comic entertainment I am your host today
Walter Binet dziak and we are talking
about something we have not covered yet
on the show Game of Thrones yes I'm very
excited to get into this this is my
favorite show on TV right now I think it
might speak for Porter maybe you
absolutely will get into it
speaking of Porter mr. Brian Porter
how's it going so some of you might not
know infinity easy that's what that says
not sure if you can see there it says
yeah you ready to talk game of Thrones
yes always answer I am away how's it
going pal I am I went half wildling half
legs and arias you know like yeah I
can't choose there's too many badass
chicks in this problem you're right and
speaking of too much I mean there's too
much to talk about with this show so
we're gonna have a Facebook exclusive
going up on facebook.com slash awesome
comics show later this week probably on
Thursday so go ahead and check that out
it's gonna be more Game of Thrones talk
so if you can't get enough G ot check it
out on a Facebook and let's get into it
right now okay Game of Thrones Season
six we're here to ask a question is Game
of Thrones Season six the best season of
the show yet let's go to Porter first
what do you think yes I I think so it
was the the season they had like the
most it balanced to it as far as highs
and normal blows the crushing roll
there's always that problem and then
it's the season actually we think we
progressed the most story-wise and
because I know my you know issues with
the show occasionally were just either
repeating storylines or just you know
taking a step forward and two steps back
a certain character especially Daenerys
or whatever and so I feel like we
covered the most ground in this season
and really setting shit up and it's like
finally six years to actually really get
somewhere in certain places and it's
like yes so I'm super excited for season
seven but yes season six for me Bryan
favorite
okay cool I know what you think season
six best season if you would have asked
me the for the last two episodes before
battle the bastards I would have said
it's a great season it's still I think
less frustrating than season five in my
book but I would have said no probably
not the best and then those last two
episodes happened I was like wha this is
amazing over again and so much happen
and we got so much like frustration out
of our systems and yes finally some of
the heroes like we're winning and some
of the terrible people got what's coming
to them and obviously we've we've had
some like deaths and some lows and like
before the last couple episodes that
happened but it was sort of nothing like
Creek like two out of the ordinary there
were like some surprises that were kind
of used to but there I would say not too
much until those last two episodes and
you're like yes finally yes yes we were
we were all in that Christmas story
moment oh yes just in case I don't know
why you would not get any of this but
spoilers yeah just in case right we're
gonna be talking about all those easy
yeah we're talking about allowed to show
most of season 6 so if you even a cop on
the show yet I go watch the show it's
totally worth it then come back here
yeah but yeah so you're saying season 6
is the best season yeah alright I think
I am - I mean it is by far the most
satisfying season I think we all pretty
much agree with that season 5 was such a
downer
I can't employ anything yeah the the
most like just depressing episode after
episode like terrible terrible terrible
terrible and I almost stopped watching
it after I think people really upset
about the Sansa the Sansa thing oh yeah
that was a big thing in there with
Ramsay and Sansa like that Fionna and
there has been rape on the show before
so that was you know an element to the
show that it was something really
comfortable with but yeah it's something
they took farther than I think was nice
yeah for sure the show B is like it you
know you're gonna see that type of stuff
specially in like the medieval times
like that yeah that was a part of that
time unfortunately but what to show it
and to have it in that much detail for a
character that we loved was a little
much yeah but at the same time I was
also kind of expecting Ramsay was so
evil at that point and that really
pushed him over I kind of expected that
to happen yeah wasn't so it wasn't like
a shocking thing the thing that I would
almost stop watching is when they killed
Shireen stands his daughter that's when
I was like I
this isn't like giving me any joy like
what is the point in coming back to this
week after week if I'm just gonna feel
like crap after watching the show yeah
oh and then you find out the fact that
that never even happened in the book
right and then they didn't even serve
any pieces right they might they might
be leading that up to that and the winds
of winter whenever that comes out and
2015 yeah yeah that was just that was
like a point where like you really just
were kicking us when we were down and we
didn't need that in season five and then
of course Jon's death at the end of
season five was another unfortunate
thing I think we all knew he was
probably gonna come back but still it
was like it was still devastating yeah a
little shit yeah right so that whole
just that whole or around that season
was just you know like I said kicking us
when we're down and just like oh god it
just keeps getting worse so we needed
season six and it was like the perfect
counterbalance to the end of all of
season five I think um they didn't one
of the things I liked about season six
is they didn't me and ER in things like
we all know Jenna was coming back so
second episode he's back
we know one like the frickin stuff with
Daenerys going back with the Dothraki
and she snapped out of that as soon as
it happens was like no I thought the
same exact thing I was like man where
she gets to by the end is freaking
amazing
yeah let's talk about the nurse a little
bit yeah Daenerys obviously like we said
at the beginning of this season was in a
spot that nobody who's watching this
show wanted to see her in yep she was
regressing she went back that Dothraki
got captured and everything and nobody
wanted to see that but like I said they
were smart enough to
wrap that up pretty quick and it showed
her growth of character that she's not
gonna deal with this little BS anymore
and it also helped progress the story
because she got all those Dothraki right
yeah there's just amassed a huge army so
it's like okay we're making progress
exactly so by the end of season six
Daenerys is finally sailing towards
Westeros which is it's very close
between that and the stuff with Ramsay
and and John and Sansa like what was
more satisfying but I mean we were
waiting we've been waiting for this for
six whole seasons for her to DeSales
their Westeros so she's finally gotten
her a whole army she's got an alliance
in Westeros with Dorne and the Tyrells
so hi gardens on her side as well so
this whole thing building up is finally
gonna happen and we get to see that big
wide shot of like all the ships at the
end that's like the last moment of the
season and that's a huge arc for her I
think seeing even just having the
dragons and writing the dragons and
being like yep
set them on fire you get a fireball you
when she was like messing him up with
the boats and just sitting the boats on
fire and that and then what was it worm
worm toccatas what's a worm great room
great worm and then he's like talking
those dudes or whatever and you just
slowly just yeah I make the deal girls
every one of them dies and then they're
like okay this one he's an outsider and
he's like all right kill the other two
cheering goes I'm like tell everybody
what happened he's just like it's super
serious yeah it's great but he still has
that little tinge to him but yeah Danny
made a lot of progress in this season I
think talking about another character
let's talk about Jon Snow and my
personal favorite character at the
beginning the season he was dead at the
end of this season he's a badass he's a
badass in Lord of Winterfell and now the
king of the north right yeah by the way
that moment who that was that's awesome
yeah that's little Lyanna Mormont can we
talk about me she's a badass actress
yeah so big in that power that's packed
into this tiny little like she's got
like this stare that it's like I
wouldn't want to like ever mess with her
in like a million years
who'd kill me yeah oh great performance
from that kid
yeah and a great addition one of my like
than like newbies might be one of my new
favorite character yeah I don't like I'm
Lana see everybody loves her yes she's
Grail we get more of her absolutely in
her little speech to you know spurn the
door thing great oh she just comes off
very natural you know she just comes off
like naturally very authoritarian kind
of yeah yeah I think she and she has
Authority as a kid it's not some bratty
kid being like it's my like Joffrey
being like I am The King well yeah
there's no feeling like that if you have
to tell people the king then maybe
you're right
but it's no she just like stands up and
you're like okay shut up yeah yeah yeah
I would say she's almost opposite
guns like art with this and like his
coming back was really satisfying the
wall and then you also know daily didn't
you have no idea where he's going
because he's like I'm not a brother or
anything and we find out I mean he
doesn't know yet but we find out through
brand and the three-eyed Raven that he
is in fact the son of that's yeah Ned's
sister Lyanna stark so yeah I mean they
didn't explicitly say in the show but I
think we all can assume that with ours
is dad with that all that push in on the
baby no but I mean just that they didn't
explicitly say that Rhaegar is the
father of it yeah I mean I think that's
yeah that's pretty much that's probably
true no yeah that's like a fan theory
that's been out there for years I was
yeah and now that it's finally confirmed
I mean we order Martin feels like even
cuz he didn't get to do that reveal in
his book and take so damn long I mean
it's the same time it's like do you want
to rush him to make it a inferior
product or do you want to you know get I
want an on board proper thing just just
light a fire under his ass you know I
like seeing pictures of him just out
doing anything but riding like in a zorb
ball just like running around not
writing and you're like I keep following
them I found on Twitter knee keeps
posting like these these blogs like
these really long blogs and like every
comment it's like where's words wouldn't
winter yeah and just like in salting oh
my gosh
I feel bad for my dance come out like
2012 or something it doesn't good pretty
sure that guy can take the hate because
ya hate minions yeah just wait right but
we got that big reveal I mean people in
waiting for years to see that and it
finally came up John is probably a
Targaryen so that's amazing
so John had a big big arc as well bran
had a big arc he took season 5 off came
back and got that whole thing just
seeing the path
than having him just witness all the
stuff especially tower to joy man tower
Joyce that's great that was that was
amazing yeah that was so excited
fantasticks swordfights there young Ned
like yeah that was like some of those
flashbacks to of like earlier seasons we
get to see other people basically saying
the same lines like lift up your most
appears shield or oh hey that's a line
that Jon Snow so I was like earlier in
the series so I love like the little
like nods to like other characters yeah
yeah that whole stuff was great even the
terrifying when brand like went into the
when he brought his eyes back whatever
you call it whenever whatever you call
whenever et time-travel kind of but was
seeing the the night king and the entire
army of White Walkers and the night King
touches is yeah that was terrifying Gary
I mean obviously right over there at God
and then that Lee bring to the door okay
we'll go into the door here because we
have some dissenting opinions on this so
this is obviously right yeah this is
when Hodor dies and it is a it rips
ripped my heart out the porter start out
and just seeing the tragic yeah let's
let's lay the groundwork here so late
yeah they we see simultaneously what was
happening in the past and the present
and it both involved brand whirring into
Hodor and basically fried his brain and
kind of melded his brains at two
different points in his life and yeah
through them over so he stuck there I
think gave him one kinda like a seizure
sort of and just didn't totally screw
with his mind and then he dies for his
friends they're holding the door so that
the whites don't get to brand so you
just hear you hear what's-her-name
screaming that and then he's the young
Hodor screaming in and it just blends
into Hodor and it is like oh no
happening just just it was like it was
like just this thing slowly closing in
on me like what oh oh
Oh Oh and then they turn to tears yeah
absolutely I cry full tears I didn't
like open Eddy steady tears and I think
it's the saddest thing that's happened
in the show not the most deplorable
thing but I'm like one of the very like
only people that think this it was sad
it was very sad I would give you that
order a code or isn't innocent once he
was the most innocent character in the
entire country no it's not that sad like
he wasn't I there were there were sad or
moments in the series of beloved care
what do you think is I I said it to you
before the honestly red wedding was one
of those that was like that was my heart
brings no sense it was it was sad it was
like a whole bunch of these right code
or it was totally sad but like after
watching the episode like I had friends
turning to me like oh my god wasn't it
the saddest thing ever aren't you crying
and I was like no that's fine I mean
people react people react to things
differently so I understand that but
like red wedding for me was just
shocking crazy maddening and sad all
mixed in and it was more of feeling of
numbness after that for me Hodor I felt
all those emotions happening okay where
is okay Hodor was one of those that sort
of crescendoed into a death though where
it was like they're running they're
running someone's gonna die I mean I was
I didn't have much hope there whereas
like the red wedding for example like I
think there was like hope and like
things were coming together and all this
stuff and then all of a sudden you get
that ripped away from you so you have
the moment of having like this positive
and all this stuff and then they go just
spare where is this other one where
you're like it's sad it's sad
Oh God okay just end it like just just
kill someone okay
thank god that's over you know so I mean
I disagree I think was like fine like I
said hold the door and then
you know the back-and-forth between
young Hodor but then also seeing and
hearing the hands ripping into Hodor and
still i mean holding the door like
you're seeing the genesis of like what
ruined his life I mean that's kind of
what and you're seeing him die at the
same time it's like a double punch yeah
that's what really got to me and Brian
realizing what's going on and knowing
that oh shit I'm causing this thing
seeing young Hodor convulsing on the
ground then Brian crying it's like he
knows that he did yeah yeah and it's
like to see that pain in him with all
the other pain it's just like I'm gonna
go cry in my room for a day like yeah so
that that's just one of the moments in
the season though that I think made it
the best really quickly favorite
episodes because we run out of time for
sure right a great filmmaking - I mean
like look at some of the back behind the
scenes stuff on that is incredible oh my
god frickin rickeon i was like zig zag
bro yeah why would you run straight
arrows being shot behind so don't do
what he wants to do terrible but John
just kind of turning and then just
taking out a sword right and that wall
of horses that's like the most iconic
shots in the entire series that's gonna
be remembered even though even when they
like went around them in the you would
like the pinch of shape or whatever and
they closed in on them with the shield's
and have that like that oh yeah behind
them has the arrows and the troll
jabbing into them and just breaking them
down like row by row oh it was
heartbreaking
we got a really severe
that was my favorite episode 2 of the
season that was terrifying I know what
you mean I think I'm right there with
you guys but alabaster's is great also
hold the door for that emotion Ramsay
you know what we're gonna talk about
Ramsay exclusive because we gotta go
guys and we're gonna talk about picks of
the week and more stuff about Game of
Thrones this Thursday on Facebook
facebook.com slash awesome comic show
make sure you like that page where can
we find the guys on social media we have
to wrap it up I have those are good
things to find you on facebook on /
austin porter twitter porkchop o 289
okay cool and you can find me on twitter
and awesome underscore walter i'll let
you guys know when I put that Facebook
page up but will be up soon and again
one more time like the Facebook page
facebook.com slash awesome comic show we
will continue the conversation go into
pics of the week I have these things
here and we'll talk about Ramsey we all
hate Ramsey and why we'll talk about it
soon and one more thing are you guys
looking forward to season 7 yes oh yeah
it's gonna be great potential dragon see
what happens we'll find out next time on
Game of Thrones so until next week guys
we'll see you on the next page
[Music]
[Applause]
you